Let’s talk about the fight over the South China Sea.
It’s rich in oil and gas, there are loads of fish
and the shipping lanes are some of the busiest
in the world.
China wants control of it.
But other countries say they have rights to it too.
And the Americans — well they have trade routes
through there worth hundreds of billions of dollars.
So what’s behind China’s claim over these waters?
Why won’t it share?
And could it all lead to war?
China has been a land-based power for millennia
so it’s never had
much of a navy
until now.
Today China wants to be a naval force across two oceans
the Indian and the Pacific.
That’s to make
sure it can trade
with the rest of the world and get enough oil and gas
to drive its economy.
And to do that
Beijing wants to control
the South China Sea.
But there’s a lot of competition.
Taiwan, for one, claims
many of the same rights
that China does.
Then there’s Vietnam, the Philippines, Malaysia
and Brunei
they want to
protect their turf
whether it’s rights to islands, seabed oil or fishing grounds.
Indonesia’s in there too.
And the Americans
they want to protect those valuable shipping lanes.
So no shortage of players.
The question is how is this all going to be resolved?
And then there’s the third option which involves
pushing some kind of compromise between
China and its neighbours.
Countries like Taiwan and others
that are members of ASEAN have tried.
But no one expects that to go anywhere anytime soon
because China knows
what it wants.
And it’s been working towards that for a long time.
We’re talking about
China’s nine dash line.
Back in 1929 the Chinese took a bunch of old British
sailing charts and told cartographers to draw
China’s borders.
One of them drew nine dashes
around the entire
South China Sea.
And as far as the Chinese were concerned that was that.
So then in 2013 China added a tenth line to take in Taiwan.
Its appetite seems
to be growing.
It’s easy enough to understand why China
wants control when you
look at the numbers.
Around 40% of the world’s liquefied natural gas
passes through the South China Sea — from the Gulf
through the Indian Ocean and on to places like China.
The amount of trade that
sails through there
is worth $3 trillion a year — one-third of the world total.
So there’s an expression in Latin that goes:
If you want peace
prepare for war.
Now China has no immediate interest in war
but it wants to ensure its access to the South China Sea
if it comes to that.
In the west the main
shipping lane
from the Indian Ocean narrows to just 3 km.
And it’s surrounded by American allies.
In the east there’s Taiwan
which has tonnes of
American weapons
and could block China from getting to the Pacific.
So to help stake its
territorial claim
China has planted its flag on contested islands
that are in those waterways.
In the Paracels China’s built a bunch of outposts
while in the Spratlys it’s
added over 13 sq km
of reclaimed land since 2013
and turned them into
military bases.
It may be unacceptable
to the Americans
but neither the Obama nor the Trump administrations
are seen to have
accomplished much.
The US’ main way of asserting navigational rights
and freedoms is having its navy sail
through the South China Sea.
It also conducts military exercises in the region
sometimes with warships from France, Japan
and Australia in
the Bay of Bengal.
In July things got a bit hairy.
The Chinese and Americans both held naval exercises
in the South China Sea.
The US sailed in with two aircraft carrier strike groups.
And the Chinese
accused the Americans
of escalating things.
Before the US elections
the Trump team
gave it one last shot — with mixed results.
What everyone’s been trying to do is get China
to obey the law — namely
the UN Convention
on the Law of the Sea.
The law establishes
what are called
exclusive economic zones.
These extend
200 nautical miles
out from a country’s coastline
regardless of whether it’s the mainland or an island.
And China signed
up to that law.
So the Philippines did the only thing it could.
It took China to court.
One of the big issues was fishing rights.
In 2013 the Philippines argued that China had no right
to the Scarborough Shoal.
It filed a case
against the Chinese
with an international
tribunal at The Hague.
Judges ended up siding
with the Philippines.
Remember China’s
territorial claim based
on that nine dash line?
Well in 2016 the court concluded that it’s invalid.
Since the 1990s ASEAN
that association of South Asian countries
has tried to cobble together a Code of Conduct
for the South China Sea.
The idea was to control China’s ambitions.
China hadn’t shown much interest in a code back then.
But after losing the case
with the Philippines
the Chinese started
to push for one.
Though some in ASEAN questioned their motives.
There’s another problem.
Not everyone in ASEAN is eager to offend a country
as powerful as China.
Vietnam has repeatedly butted heads with China
over their competing claims.
This year’s ASEAN summit was hosted by Vietnam
and a lot of it by video because of the pandemic.
But the social distancing wasn’t expected to help
delegates reach any agreements
on the South China Sea.
The problem with the
South China Sea
is that it’s vast and the
stakes are high.
There are a lot of heavily armed countries
defending their
interests there.
And China’s coastguard as well as Chinese militia
using fishing boats often cause confrontations
on the open sea.
Many analysts worry about all of that provoking
a military response
from someone.
But strangely enough
the whole dispute
also sort of just bubbles
away under the radar.
The Chinese see the
South China Sea
as essential to their survival.
Thing is it’s important to everyone there.
That’s why this whole dispute isn’t going away.
But China’s been around for thousands of years.
If anyone is good at playing the long game, it’s China.
As with all our Start Here episodes this primer
is to get us started.
But there’s a lot more information out there to help
us understand what’s going on in the South China Sea.
As always subscribe wherever you’re watching this video
and I’ll see you next week.